[Musica]
[Applauso]
limitare rafforzamento perché queste due
parole si accostano insieme fragilità
perché rappresenta una condizione una
condizione della persona che è una
condizione clinica fisiologica
biomeccanica ma anche una condizione
della propria prospettiva personale
anche in relazione alla società e
rafforzamento perché io sono convinta da
ricercatore di bioingegneria che ha
lavorato tutta la vita professionale su
questo tema che la tecnologia la scienza
la ricerca possano trovare una soluzione
alla fragilità e trasformare la
fragilità in abilità e qualità della
vita impossibilità di essere autonomi e
comunque di partecipare alla società e
di provvedere anche a se stessi
lavorando la fragilità è una condizione
difficile che è una condizione umana che
noi scienziati definiamo con una serie
di fattori che riguardano le cosiddette
abilità alle abilità cognitive le
abilità fisiche si possono misurare ma è
una condizione dalla quale si può uscire
oggi con la pandemia ha il cod
abbiamo scoperto che la fragilità in chi
espone voi ciascuno in più al virus
espone anche a dei peggioramenti della
salute per cui chi ha una fragilità
rischia di più dice di stare male o di
morire per cui tutti quanti hanno
imparato questo concetto
ma che cosa è legato può essere legato
all'età a causa dell'invecchiamento e
quindi del fatto che le condizioni
fisiche non sono più le stesse con l'età
e che siamo quindi un peggioramento
complessivo può essere legato alla
cosiddetta cronicità e la cronicità
significa quando una persona soffre di
una malattia per esempio la malattia
neurodegenerativa
il morbo di parkinson o una malattia
rara una malattia che che porta ad avere
una particolare sofferenza e anche una
convivenza
con questa malattia ha una sopravvivenza
perché spesso la medicina consente di
superare degli eventi anche per esempio
nelle malattie o degli eventi
particolari drammatici e attraverso
quella che cosiddetta cronicizzazione
della malattia per cui si vive si vide
un po peggio ma si continua a bere
oppure può essere legata a problemi
sociali e di difficoltà o al fatto che
ci possono essere delle cause per
esempio una disabilità anche una
disabilità congenita per cui una persona
è più fragile ecco queste sono le varie
condizioni che abbiamo davanti e
dobbiamo far sì come ricercatori come
persone impegnate nella scienza di
riuscire a elitari che la società
trascorrere questa fragilità di una
persona che ha per esempio la malattia
in una causa di vulnerabilità perché
dalla fragilità alla vulnerabilità si
sta un po peggio si dipende di più dagli
altri e si sa piu a rischio per esempio
verso un virus o verso un altro evento
che può far star peggio
oppure dopo la vulnerabilità è un altro
evento è un'altra causa come può un
virus si può dipendere totalmente
dall'aiuto degli altri e si diventa
totalmente disabili al quando era a me
piace dire lo tifo anche a lezione agli
studenti che la disabilità è una causa
cioè causata dalla società cioè non è
una caratteristica della persona è
causata dal fatto che una persona ha
delle vulnerabilità delle abilità
limitate dovute alla malattia all
incidente e la società lo mette in grado
di partecipare dal mettere le scale
troppo alte al mettere degli ostacoli
per la strada a impedire di partecipare
queste sono cose che noi possiamo
evitare se disegniamo meglio i nostri
edifici se prepariamo la nostra
struttura e le nostre infrastrutture per
essere accessibili a tutti quindi
l'impegno della bioingegneria quello
[Musica]
che una fragilità si trasformi in
disabilità e indipendenza e quindi
garantire una qualità della vita e una
partecipazione perché le persone
vogliono essere produttive provvedere a
se stessi lavorare e stare in società in
mezzo agli altri
anche perché l'isolamento come abbiamo
visto in questi giorni può addirittura
provocare un peggioramento della
situazione ecco allora quali sono le
soluzioni tecnologiche che noi ci
possiamo immaginare
per evitare questo problema sono
soluzioni che in gergo bioingegneristico
si chiamano soluzioni socio tecnologiche
cosa significa significa che noi
possiamo trasformare la casa la casa con
una serie di sensori di sistemi
indossabili di apparecchiature che
trasformano la casa senza renderla un
ospedale quindi in modo anche invisibile
rispetto alla struttura ma permette per
me sono tutte queste fra strutture di
monitorare per esempio lo stato
fisiologico di una persona quindi avere
sensori che sono indossati che possono
monitorare per esempio il rischio di
caduta a un andato una sbagliata o un
evento che sta per venire per esempio il
battito cardiaco e quindi utilizzare le
tecnologie che sono già per esempio
commerciali e disponibili non lo so
iwatch di dear con suite bit che è stato
comprato da google cioè orologi che
misurano i parametri fisiologici che
oggi con grandi esperimenti che
coinvolgono milioni di soggetti si
dimostrano essere utilizzabili anche per
avere un monitoraggio medico ecco che la
telemedicina da sogno un anno fa se ne
parlava con una cosa futuristica oggi
diventa uno strumento fondamentale
perché monitorare parametri fisiologici
può consentire di vivere una cronicità
per esempio una predisposizione al
rischio cardiologico in modo tranquillo
a casa monitorato da sensori indossabili
perché poi si può fare di più sono solo
tecnologico vuol dire che posso
aggiungere lo bravo per esempio un robot
che possa portare support supporto
cognitivo e riconoscere dal modo di
corse o di muoversi in una persona
rispetto
robot se c'è per esempio un incipiente
demenza che sta arrivando e quindi
monitorare le persone con quello che si
chiama ma il comite impairment ed
aiutarla svolgere esercizi terapie
riabilitative che possono consentire un
rallentamento del peggioramento e quindi
una cronicità che non evolve nel peggio
ma che si mantiene o addirittura
progredisce è uscito proprio qualche
settimana fa un importantissimo studio
dell'organizzazione mondiale della
sanità che dice che si è dimostrato che
tutte queste malattie che io poi ho
elencato in modo un po divulgativo ma
per farmi capire a tutti possono essere
talmente diffuse soprattutto con un
aumento dell'aspettativa di vita quindi
molti anni davanti per fortuna grazie ai
trattamenti appunti per cui circa un
terzo della popolazione potrebbe
beneficiare da terapie riabilitative
perché se noi utilizzassero delle
terapie cognitive anche somministrata
attraverso il tablet come quello che ho
io questo mio tavolo con i miei appunti
o con un robot che svolgere degli
esercizi e fa quello che si si dice
engagement cognitivo quindi coinvolge in
un gioco che si chiama serious game che
consente alla persona di avere lontanto
è solo intrattenimento ma anche una
terapia che rallenta a utilizzare il
cervello coinvolge e può essere
monitorata in modo remoto da opportuni
clinici personale clinico che riescono
avere quelli che si chiamano in gergo
clinico alert cioè quella persona sta
per avere una mente oppure sta
peggiorando da un somministra una
terapia quindi solo show tecnologia
perché perché tecnologia è la soluzione
tecnologica allora lascio indossabile il
robot il tablet diventa una suite
quindi non un device ma una suite di
dispositivi immersi nella casa che non
cambiano l'ambiente domestico ma
consentono di monitorare lo stato di
salute questo è possibile oggi perché i
dati che si generano sono tantissimi big
data e grazie al matching e algoritmi di
analisi dei dati possiamo generare
realista automatici chiamare il clinico
quindi non affidare la decisione
semplicemente
il sistema robotico all'intelligenza
artificiale ma a chiamare in causa e
clinico quando ci sono degli alert e
questo potrebbe essere un ruolo
importante quindi l'organizzazione
mondiale della sanità ha detto su lancet
qualche giorno fa che il terzo della
popolazione mondiale potrebbe
beneficiare da terapie riabilitative
quindi non è che io voglio somministrare
terapie riabilitative a chi non ne ha
bisogno ma si dimostra appropriato per
persone che hanno cronicità anche
utilizzando tecnologie e quindi guidati
negli esercizi motori guidato gli
esercizi cognitivi possono quindi trarre
beneficio qual è il passaggio ulteriore
è quello che si chiama oggi digital
coaching le nuove terapie digitali e
nuove terapie digitali inseriscono un
altro salto di qualità rispetto a quello
che ho detto finora perché oltre ad
avere dei sistemi distribuiti con un
controllo intelligenza si stanno bene
possono anche avere una app che si
chiama un digital coach che può avere
l'apparenza di un robot di un agente
virtuale questo noi ricercatori dobbiamo
ancora studiare qual è l'apparenza
migliore però che cosa fa aiuta a
cambiare il comportamento durante le
fasi della complicità che spinesi un
istante se una persona che ha un rischio
ed etica un rischio di peggioramento
della propria condizione di salute un
dei alcologico sentire di fare quello
che noi scienza che diciamo cambiare il
comportamento che significa significa
modulare la nutrizione secondo il
bisogno significa subire le attività
fisica quando ce n'è bisogno e
opportunamente guidata cambiare lo stile
di vita perché lo stile di vita è
determinante per vivere una cronicità
nel modo migliore possibile
hanno invece di somministrare un farmaco
quelle che si chiamano norma mette le
terapie questa terapia digitale sviluppa
un algoritmo che tavola insegnarli segna
ex terni da eventuali sensori
indossabili per i diabetici sarà il
glucosio per i cardiopatici sarà il
battito cardiaco ovviamente e quindi i
segnali
fisiologici rilevanti i segnali dei
meccanici fisco logici significa che si
riferiscono allo stato fisiologico del
paziente biomeccanici alla sua atto di
movimento e innamora un suggerimento un
suggerimento che è il coaching a una
specie di che di aver virtuale di
persona che si prende cura virtualmente
e aiuta a cambiare lo stile di vita
questo può aiutare
sicuramente a migliorare lo stile di
vita e quindi migliorare le proprie
condizioni
io credo che ci sarà un futuro per
queste terapie digitali prima di tutto
perché consentono una grande libertà di
vivere da soli di vivere in modo
autonomo di non avere sempre bisogno
perchè il river che dà consigli e
accompagnano una persona a vivere e vive
la propria cronicità in collaborazione
con sul sistema di digital coaching fate
per conto che in germania non sviluppato
una app per la persona che hanno
sofferto di depressione maggiore che
consente a queste persone di avere un 10
dal coaching che magari somministra una
terapia che significa una terapia che
insegna a respirare a muoversi a
svolgere delle azioni a cambiare stile
di vita e quindi il comportamento perché
il comportamento incide
ecco perché io parlo di rafforzamento
parlo di fragilità una persona che ha
sofferto di una depressione maggiore
quindi è più esposta alle situazioni di
criticità soprattutto se sta con soste
in situazioni socio economici presi
ficili si isola e non è non è possibile
assistere nel modo dovuto con questi
sistemi con un costo relativamente basso
dovrebbe essere possibile seguirle in
modo migliore
quali sono i passaggi importanti il
primo è la formazione il personale
clinico paramedico i professionisti
devono essere formati per utilizzare
questo ha senso se c'è una prescrizione
cioè una modulare la terapia
secondo il bisogno e l'allestimento e 7
tecnologico secondo episodio è la
formazione molto importante e delicata
in un momento in cui a causa soprattutto
nel codice ci ha dato una spinta verso
la teleriabilitazione la teleassistenza
il digital coaching che saranno
strumenti consiglieri ma ci vorrà un
personale qualificato e preparato per
questo l'altro sono le infrastrutture
ovviamente allestire le cose perché si
possa ovviare a questo problema
il terzo il riconoscimento al sistema
sanitario non riconosce ancora la
terapia digitale in italia nel modo
giusto
e chiaro che il sistema sanitario si
deve adeguare il tempo che cambia e
capire che una riabilitazione cognitiva
per esempio durante la pandemia per
bambini che soffrono di autismo si trave
poter prescrivere e somministrare per
via di teleconferenza con gli strumenti
che non sono gli stessi strumenti che
usiamo per parlare con i familiari o per
parlare con gli amici ma sono strumenti
che rappresentano che in quel momento si
sta svolgendo una terapia prescritta dal
opportuno clinico quindi questo è
sicuramente un passaggio importante e
serve il coinvolgimento di tutti perché
noi facciamo quella che si chiama una
pressione politica sui nostri decisori
perché ci riconoscano l'importanza di
questo rivoluzione che sta avvenendo
anche perché abbiamo capito che
l'importante è l'ospedale per acuti che
ci salva in caso di eventi drammatici e
la terapia intensiva ma poi c'è tutto il
follow up non ci possiamo diventare
delle persone sul territorio soprattutto
se hanno delle cronicità o quelle che si
chiamano comorbidità più patologia allo
stesso tempo e poi che cosa serve serve
capire che la tecnologia è cambiata che
il rapporto fra noi
la robotica sta cambiando la robotica
non è più il robot a fianco antropomorfo
un maggiordomo che si immaginava nei
film di qualche anno fa ma è un robot
che può essere anche in un altro comico
ma che ci porta coach in questi casi che
si può associare per esempio una terapia
basata su dei farmaci con una pillola
intelligenti che manda un segnale
verifica l'aderenza una terapia del
paziente quindi dice effettivamente il
paziente ha appreso quella pillola e e
quindi la pillola intelligente oppure
strumenti che utilizzano neuro protesi
sistemi impiantabili che cambiano la
nostra il nostro corpo perché magari
somministrano delle terapie come può
avvenire per gli impianti per pazienti
malati di parkinson che grazie agli
impianti che ricevono sono in grado di
modulare il loro controllo motorio di
riprendere il controllo e una di qualità
della vita migliore
quindi la robotica non è più alternativa
può essere anche una robotica di
supporto così come la bionica così come
gli strumenti che noi associamo a una
suite che io mi immagino una casa
tecnologica che diventa socio
tecnologica perché specialmente tu a
rilevare lo stato di salute del paziente
e quindi la sua il suo stare bene e
inviare delle informazioni a un centro
remoto per le lauree
[Applauso]